all right Diana Diana where you from
originally where'd you grow up uh I grew
up in Vermont I was born in Illinois but
I I would say that I grew up in Vermont
because we moved here when I was pretty
young and tell me about your uh family
growing
up
um uh messy parents messy drug addict
parents they were they were only
together until I was
probably three or four five something
like that four
kids um lots of
stepdads um feral child we like raised
ourselves
and weren't really given any kind of
tools to to do that you know cuz kids
don't have that they don't just
naturally possess it and so it was a
free-for-all kind of on your own older
siblings acted more like parents than my
actual parents and they were all [__]
up too so what are they going to you
know um how would you describe your
childhood a [__] mess just an
absolute [__] show I mean there were
obviously like sprinkles of of happiness
and my mother's an artist so there were
there memories of of Art and music and
you know some nurturing but at some
point in her own childhood she she her
maternal Instinct was just removed or
damaged too deeply to to be like an
animal mother and and I think drug drug
SE to become the first PRI drugs and
alcohol and well mainly men cuz even
when she's like sober it's her man is
more important
and um takes priority over anything else
kids are sort of like the consequence of
a relationship but not necessarily you
know I can't even remember the first
time I heard I never wanted kids and I
never wanted to be married like it was
just like a from three to four or five
that like that was we just knew that we
just knew that that was how she felt and
and it was hugely apparent in her
behavior that it was not something that
she did joyfully it was sort of like I
just have to deal with you guys so which
is unfortunate because she was like my
mother and
father are both incredibly talented
intelligent people they're just both
deeply damaged and so we I I've joked
many times in my life that I got this
like Lottery of genetics where they're
both really intelligent people we're all
artists and but but all tremendously
[__] up based on our genetics and then
our upbringing and
um yeah it's unfortunate cuz they could
have nurtured that my youngest brother
there
um boy girl girl
boy he's like the most quote normal like
he did everything the way you're
supposed to do it you know went to
college he's still with the person he
lost his virginity to he's married has
has a daughter um he was nurtured the
most and the theory that I've come to
believe is like when a child has you
know their their basic needs met and
beyond that they can they can flourish
into the person that they were supposed
to become but when you have to worry
about safety
and you know all these other things that
humans aren't supposed to have to worry
about when they're trying to grow and be
their best selves like
you end up with a damaged person and and
that's been the reality for you
know for my mother's kids and for myself
and in this journey that I've been on of
of trying to unfuck that like unfuck my
head to to the point where you know I I
luckily realized really young that I had
a pretty dysfunctional relationship with
alcohol and knew that like the way I
drank wasn't normal really young you
know like 19 was the first time that I I
like went straight edge didn't know I
was what an alcoholic was or that I was
one
um and I've actually been sober more
than I haven't been sober in my life um
but it's taken me I'm going to be 40 and
it's taken me this this amount of time
to really fully understand what I am
like what what happened as a kid that
that made me who I am today and um you
know I've been sober this time around
and it's a big part of my story because
it's a big part of what um drives humans
is their addiction their need to feel
love their need to their need to feel
validated and complete and okay like
just feel okay but um
you know this journey that I've been on
and especially recently has been um
about so much more than being sober
really recently it's been about like
that like inner child Shadow work stuff
because you know as
I um address the disorders in the order
of severity or the order that they kill
you it's
like my feelings about myself and my
relationship to myself is is just as
detrimental as like any
addiction the partners that I choose the
relationships I allow always the case oh
absolutely
um but to be aware of that where like
you know until even up until 6 months
ago I wasn't even fully aware to the
extent that it was making choices for me
like making choices for I mean I
knew that I felt damaged I knew I
carried a lot of Shame name
um and didn't feel like like I could
demand the type of love I thought I
deserved but it I didn't realize how
much of it was subconscious like I'm
making these choices based on how I was
taught love and how I was loved as a
child and if you're not loved at all
you're completely neglected and there's
tremendous
abuse you you don't learn what your
value is as a human and so if you don't
possess that you look for it every else
and I've looked for it in drugs and
alcohol and relationships and food and
shopping and that's what I hope people
learn from my videos is that the drug
addiction is not the problem the drugs
and the alcohol are a symptom of the
problem symptom of the problem the
actual problem is the inability to love
yourself which comes
from usually from uh one or two
neglectful parents yeah you're I mean
the love that that you have for yourself
directly reflects the love that you're
taught like you're taught what love is
you're taught this is what your place in
the world is this is what love means and
if you're taught for myself I was taught
Love Hurts you love love does
harm love is not there for you love
betrays you you can't trust it and
so my relationships mirror that you know
what I mean like the men that I've
chosen to be in relationships with my
ex-husband like that's they mirror that
if you know familiar familial that whole
like there's a reason some women will
keep ending up with Partners who
absolutely who physically abuse them and
I
um this time around has been I I look at
the timeline of my life and I've been in
three big relationships and
um the first two were pretty much
identical um and it it mirrors the path
that I've been on of like self-growth
and like healing and they mirror it
completely and you you know they they
progressively got better but they also
in very in just as many ways stayed the
same and
um this last year I've just been like I
bought a house with somebody that I
didn't even
know who who was that love that I had
like only ever known and didn't even
know that I fully like fully comprehend
that's what I was doing but like nine
months ago I started um I have complex
PTSD and like you know addiction and all
this stuff and
um like N9 months ago I started looking
into like micro doing and narrow
Pathways and just sort of trying to
change change those
like thought processes around things I
felt like I couldn't control I couldn't
control how my brain reacted I couldn't
control how you know a lot of things
because it's so hardwired from you know
from birth
when you're in that environment and um
and I think that was like a big Catalyst
into into the changes that I've
experienced in the last like nine months
or so of um coming to these big these
big realizations about myself and and my
life and and how you know I'm having to
dig deep into the childhood stuff and
then also look at how I did the same
[__] as a mom like that was
like it's rough
man um you see yourself doing the same
things as your I did I did I mean I
don't know thank God I mean I've been
sober for eight years and it was like a
year and a half relapse before that and
was your drug for seven years I was
alcohol forever and then 10 years ago I
um was in a relationship with somebody
who turned out to be a drug addict and
in hindsight it seems so simple to just
like jump ship but I thought I could
save him and help him and just [__]
went down with him what was that what
drug was that
opiates um my sister is a
lifetime hard drug user and I thought I
had like dodged that Bullet cuz I you
know I was over 30 when I when ended up
getting hooked by it but
um yeah it's a that's a that that's a
tough one that you know that makes you
like I I I describe it as being
possessed by a demon like it's not you
know you don't even resemble the person
that you are there's no way you can live
true to who you really are be your
authentic self or it's the only thing
driving driving that bus
is you know this terrible need to to not
get sick like your brain just it's like
I need it more than I need [__] air
is to not be sick and there are so many
times like from you know from friends
that I had who' experienced it before me
where I had to like really practice like
you're not going to going to [__] die
like cuz you think you're going to you
think you're going to die and um there
are plenty of times where I wanted to
that's for sure you know it's a
it's it's really nothing short of a
miracle that I'm
not still in it and still there's so
many people that um that I know that
still are and and I stopped right right
at the time where fentanyl just started
really hitting like Vermont you're lucky
absolutely like right after I got sober
in 2016 and like right after that people
just started
dropping and uh and they still are all
the time there's just tons of people
from my graduating class I think about
this like whole generation of people
with you know and all this untreated
trauma and childhood stuff and they're
all
just repeating the same patterns and
creating more addicts with all their
kids and like um in the job that I have
right now I inter I'm I interact with a
lot of people that are are not doing
well and um and these last couple years
felt really compelled to try to like do
something to help and I've come up with
really ridiculous scenarios about like
like
um making chocolate chip cookies with
xlax in them and delivering them to drug
dealers and pretending I just moved to
the neighborhood and like vigilante
superhero that gives drug dealers
diarrhea
um but really you know wanting to impart
some change and feel like I can do
something to combat how did how did you
get clean I went to rehab I I went a
couple times I went to like a really
terrible like State Hospital once and it
I only lasted a couple of
days and
then
um probably like a year later I went to
a a little bit nicer one in Northern
Vermont um
you do like a ridiculous computer quiz
that gives you a score to determine how
long your stay will be and and I
remember because I'd already been sober
before I didn't answer questions about
my childhood I answered questions
according to like the last 5 years I'm
like this is what I'm addressing I've
already unpacked my childhood I don't
need to talk about my mother or any of
that stuff which is obviously hilarious
now but
um you I stayed for 21 days and uh the
night I was there I found out I was
pregnant the night I got there I found
out I was pregnant 21 days I saved like
21 22 23 days that's short that's how
much my insurance will cover oh you know
well you're you're very luy to well and
the night I like I was saying the night
I got there the night I checked in I
found out I was pregnant I have a six
and a half-year-old
and
uh you know obviously he saved my ass I
mean that's not always the case that's
the thing it's like I've had this really
intense maternal Instinct since I was a
kid and you know I look at my sister who
genetically we're very we have the same
parents um we both experienced childhood
abuse she she was molested really young
um I the first time I experienced sexual
assault I was 13 but she was even
younger and it wasn't when I when I was
assaulted it wasn't a family member
which I know that makes a difference I
know it does especially when it's
someone your stepdad you know what I
mean somebody you call Dad and it
changed her and it changed her in the
same way that it changed my mother she
just lost her Instinct as like an animal
to to be a mom and to be able to do that
and probably probably relates to how she
felt about herself like it just changes
who you
know she was she was a child and ever
since then it's been like run run run
from that and the ways that she runs
just compounds the trauma
and um she has four kids too I have four
kids she has four
kids but I been a mother to my kids I've
failed pretty badly at times pretty
badly those are the things that hurt me
the most or the ways that I've failed or
statistically done exactly what my
mother did that's the most harmful thing
for
me
um when I asked you how you did it and
you said
rehab yes that's that's way more that's
so went to rehab but there's there's
probably much more to it I got out of
rehab but I was you know I went off on
the the maternal Instinct thing because
I was pregnant and and I got out and and
I was determined that I wasn't going to
stay those 23 days I was like I'm not
staying all this time and then I found
out like around
like day 10 or something like that that
that I was going to if I got out in that
that weekend or that week or whatever it
was that I would be alone and I was like
I don't think I should do that like I
don't think I should get out of rehab
and be alone and so I was like all right
I'll
wait and and that was even that short
amount of time it was like enough time
for me to sort of get my wits about me
at least a little bit like get clear
from the drugs and then but then I also
like I I entered into this program
there's um a Dartmouth
hospital in uh
Handover uh they're like always like
leading the way and especially around
like um addiction treatment and there
was this program for mothers it's it's
amazing and it started out as you know I
was pregnant and going to these groups
once a week with other pregnant Opia
addicts and like so I didn't have to
feel all this shame and I didn't have to
feel terrible about myself and and could
also um kind of explore recovery in a
different sense i' had gone to AA for
years and done all these things where
peer support is like the main uh tool
that's used but this was a completely
different scenario and then they created
this program where once you have your
child there's like a grandmother down
the hall who watches the baby and they
have like a nurse practitioner on site
they have like resource Specialists you
have like one-on-one Psychiatry therapy
and then group group stuff and it's all
in one building one hallway like that's
great and then Vermont Medicaid give
will give you a ride like I didn't have
a car when I first got sober they will
pay for your ride cuz it's a medical
appointment and um and it's actually
really interesting because I just got
hired to work for them I just got hired
to work for there's this new role in uh
Medical Care called recovery coaching or
peer support specialist and I just got
hired
um I actually had to go do a bunch of
blood work yesterday to figure out what
immunizations I had as a child because
it's a
hospital and uh it's like full circle
like I'm I was a
client I mean I still see a therapist
through them I don't go to the groups or
anything anymore and I
don't utilize all the resources but
[Music]
um I uh couple of years ago I've worked
really really hard in the last uh eight
years and um I saved up [__] $40,000
which might as well be a million to me
and I bought a house for my
kids and uh
and then the relationship ended and it's
like threatening to [__] take it it's
like cuz I cuz like an idiot I was like
this is forever I paid for all of it
which I shouldn't have been able to do
but I made you an owner cuz you had a
good credit score and it got us a little
bit more and I knew I shouldn't have I
knew like for years when I was planning
this I was like do it by yourself so
nobody can take it from you do it by
yourself that was the plan and then I
met
somebody and forgot about the [__]
plan and trusted
him and then it was like as soon as we
moved into the house it was like he took
his mask off and was like here the [__]
I am and I was like you're every man
I've ever
loved and so for the last that was in
like that was in May and so I've been
just trying to
work and still move forward still take
opportunities that feel right I've been
a supervisor at a small natural food
co-op in Vermont for a couple of years
um and I'm actually about to give my
notice tomorrow then I'm going to go
work at Dartmouth I'm going to go like
all of this life experience all these
terrible things I've been through the
things that I've like carried the most
Shame about are are why they want me to
work there like gives me credibility to
help people who haven't gotten sober yet
that have like DC F in their lives and
have all this [__] going on to help
them navigate the things that I have and
and it's incredible that there's value
in that and you know when I the first
time I got sober for
real I was like 25
and needed to go to a [__] domestic
violence agency and needed to find all
these resources because I like my life
was a lifetime movie I've been with this
guy from 16 to 25 who was 7 years older
than me and completely abusive and
terrible and so when I had to leave the
relationship with not even a backpack of
stuff I needed all these resources I
needed to figure out how to make how to
like live because I had to leave I had
to leave with nothing and I was running
into all these these professionals who
had never lived any of the stuff I was
trying to do like it being criticized by
a woman who's supposed to be like
helping me leave this terrible abusive
relationship and you know many other
instances where I was I was dealing with
someone who clearly hadn't lived what
what I I was trying to live through
and that was kind of a motivation a long
time ago to I went to school
and um I wanted to be somebody who had
who had done what people were trying to
do so I I would explored Human Services
and especially you know addiction
treatment but then I relapsed and felt
like I didn't have any credibility so I
kind of moved away from it and went back
to the restaurant world
and
um and now you know find myself here
again where I feel like I do have the
credibility again and I and I do have
the you know even more in my resume of
what I've been through and experienced
and know how to navigate
and um
especially mothers like this whole
program I'm going to go work for is
parents it's parents who have
simultaneous addiction issues and DCF
involvement and like how do they
navigate um
building a
program that they feel will help them be
successful and like what do they need to
be successful and
um and ask you know asking them what
that is instead of telling them what it
is telling them what this is what you
need to do to be successful and be okay
they sort of I'm sure there's some
steering from professionals but you know
let them sort of tell you what their
problems are these are my problems how
can we fix them and you know
I'm think
about like that child or myself like if
I'm worrying about shelter and food and
safety and whether my kids are going to
be with me or I can't worry
about you know going to school or what I
want to do to make money or even even
therapy you know what I mean like if my
basic needs are not met like I'm not I'm
not worried about being my best self I'm
worried about eating worried about
making sure that I don't lose my [__]
house you know and I've even experienced
that I've experienced that in the last
nine months I like constantly ADV
advocating to the people I know like you
need to get a therapist you need to
address this stuff I mentor a young lady
who's
20 I'm her supervisor currently but it
just ended up being more of
a almost like a family member type
relationship where I see my a lot of me
and her
and um like you got to get a therapist
you could not have to do this when
you're 40 like me you could not have a
chain of shitty relationships because
you accepted love that's [__] you
know um and she you know she hears me a
little bit but that's kind of the nature
of the Beast with people is that like
they just kind of do what they're going
to do and I try to I mean I have
teenagers it's like great practice like
they're going to do what they're going
to do and you got to love them anyway
and be kind
and you
know luckily I have they haven't they're
not really venturing in anything too
scary yet but so it's easy right now
it's just sort of normal teenage stuff
but well you seem perfectly suited to
this new job yeah I'm pretty excited
about it and helping others is probably
the key
to fulfillment abut and keeping yourself
on track and that's been kind of the the
natural progression of this and I
actually thought about it in relation to
to what I know about your story I was
kind of talking about this with my
friends because you know N9 months to a
year ago
um because of where I work it's sort of
in the downtown area of where I live and
I was seeing um the the the first inant
instance was this young man who had like
clearly been held at there's a drug
house like up the road and he'd been
held there for hours he was beaten
really badly and he got away and we and
he appeared on the like in the like
Outdoor Cafe area of my
job and one of the women that I
supervised was sitting outside and she
texted me and she's like there's a man
out here bleeding can you please come
out here like she was scared so I went
out there and
um there had just happened to be a car
accident out front and so there was
police there and someone grabbed one of
them and he came over and the way that
he was interacting with him was like not
like a person who was bleeding from his
head it was like I know you didn't fall
off your [__] bike tell me what
happened you know like what the [__] man
like he's bleeding from his head like
can't you [__] deal with like the
drug dealers later like I understand
that that's who you want but this is a
person who's bleeding from his head and
that sort of like started this whole
thing and I'm seeing these mothers these
women that I like kind of know
of literally just wandering around
completely
disheveled
clearly like this new Tran fentanyl
[__] like just a mess a [__] mess
this isn't heroin this is like a [__]
mess and I'm like I need to do something
like I need I there's no in rural
Vermont there's no Hub there's no you
don't you don't just walk down the
street and see homeless people that's
not how it works there like they're
dispersed they're in abandoned buildings
like there's nowhere for me to go and
just be like hey want a bottle of water
want you know give them necessities and
and maybe try to have a conversation
with them and so it sort of progressed
into this thing where I'm joking about
like giving drug dealers diarrhea
through chocolate chip cookies with xlax
to like what can I actually do to impart
some change and you know reaching out to
different people and and through like my
therapists or people connected to
um uh
um the addiction outpatient at Dartmouth
like can I like what can I do to help
and then it just turned into this thing
like well we have this job do you you
should apply for it you should apply for
this position and then I look at the the
the job description it's like oh you
need a bachelor's degree and all this
stuff and I'm like like why are you
telling me to apply for this like I
don't have these credentials I don't
have these degrees and so I do it and
it's basically like your lived
experience is is is enough
to is to help somebody through this and
that's like the natural thing it's like
I just felt like I needed to do
something and now I get to actually do
it and I'll get paid to do it and you
know what
um and it's incredible because I I'm
doing this at the job that I currently
have I'm doing things like this like I'm
getting pulled into these human resource
related issues and
whatever but only when it suits my
supervisor not when it's actually needed
or and I've supervised people with with
addiction issues I mean I'm a person
with addiction issues but like they're
kind of dormant right now
they're um or at least like not as
severe
um yeah it's just been a natural
progression to get here and I feel like
it's sort of like every every step of
the
way it's been just more confirmation
from the universe that I'm like right
where I'm supposed to be that I'm doing
and and that comes back to like am I
am
I am I being the truest version of
myself have I Stripped Away enough of
the [__] disorder have I Stripped
Away enough of the [__] lenses that
of my childhood these distorted ways of
thinking and believing the lies about
myself that my parents told me so that I
can see what it is I'm supposed to be
doing I can feel the stuff I'm supposed
to do I can see the opportunities I talk
about it being like in the right place
at the right time instead of my disease
or my disorders is leading me to all the
wrong places because my instincts are
maladaptive and I'm just trying to find
love and validation you know what I mean
do you do you honestly feel like you
deserve to [__] absolutely absolutely
and that's been like that's pretty
recent like just that that's like the
most important the Catalyst was like
that this this relationship [__]
imploded and I'm sitting on my porch and
I'm like who the [__] is this person
like I don't even know who this person
is and then I'm immediately like the
progression is like you stupid [__]
like how the [__] did you end up here
again when you when you stayed single
you got healthy you you you went into it
for all the right reasons you didn't
need anybody you were completely
independent like you did it all then you
[__] ended up right where you were 10
years ago with that [__] like so the
the understanding has evolved into you
know at first it's just like you [__]
[__] like how'd you end up here and
then it's like well of course you ended
up here because you saw the signs really
early on you just said if they're
willing to love you and you're a piece
of [__] then you need to be willing to
accept their [__] love if their love
is harmful and not loyal and shitty and
hurts you need to be willing to accept
that because you're a [__] single mom
who's a drug addict like you don't
deserve more than that you know and
that's [__] like that's absolute
[__] and the progression has been
like
you
know realizing that realizing that that
was the thought process where does that
[__] come from why do I believe that
about myself why do I believe I I am my
disorder I am my mistakes that was a
huge realization for me that sh shame is
that I am wrong I am bad I am my disease
I am all the mistakes I've made and
guilt is like a healthy relationship to
the shitty things you've done I feel
guilty for the stuff that I did but I
don't carry shame anymore because it's
that isn't inherently who I am it's a
it's a facet of who I am it's a symptom
of my childhood like this disordered
thinking and this need to find love in
other people I need someone to tell me
I'm good I need someone to tell me I'm
worthy that I'm okay that I'm
valued and realizing that if I don't
[__] do that for myself I'm going to
cons consistently just do everything
over again the universe gives you all
the lessons over and over and over until
you [__] learn your lesson touch the
stove 10 times burn my hand 10 times
until I'm finally like okay I see now I
get it I get the lesson I'm not going to
do it again I've recognized what I
needed to learn and I you know that's
just how life goes sometimes like
I I could regret that I that I wasn't
aware enough to make better choices or
didn't love myself enough to make better
choices but I'm so grateful that at
least I [__] know now you know like I
I know these things now and it's like
you can't once you look behind the
curtain you can't close it again you
know like that great I'm grateful for
that I mean I guess if I relapsed or you
know digressed somehow I could forget I
could forget the things that I've is
there is there any chance of that I
don't think so I mean I I don't want to
say that it's not possible cuz I feel
like there's a little bit of like danger
in doing
that but I think that especially with
the progression of my disease like
there's there's these theories that like
it progresses while you're sober and the
progression for me was like I became
like straight edge as a kid and then I
got [__] married at 21 and became a
mom and was with this terrible older
older guy and was quote sober but there
was no recovery so it was you know just
progressing I was still emotionally 14
years old and trying to go through these
things and when the Rel relationship
ended and it was traumatic I coped
exactly how I always had which was
through alcohol I started smoking
cigarettes again and and and my disease
progressed in a couple of years to where
I'm like dabbling in
opiates got sober was sober for 7 years
and when I relapsed again it was like
straight shot to opiates from there when
I'm like oh I dodged a bullet I'm like
everybody around me is addicted to
opiates I'm I'm good I must just I'm
there's there's no separation between
alcohol and drugs like it's all
addiction it's all the same receptors
it's all the same [__] it for me I'm
like oh I'm just an alcoholic I'm not a
drug addict I'm fine and it just but
yeah it's just
impossible I
I experienced enough
hell with opiate
addiction and it's still so visceral
even even eight years later it's still
so visceral like I had to go get blood
drawn yesterday for the second time in
like 4 days because they couldn't get it
the first time cuz I just have terrible
veins anyway but I was dehydrated and it
was just like torture and then yesterday
I'm like getting blood drawn and I'm
like I feel like I was going to throw up
because I I was a drug addict I was a
heroin
addict I haven't talked to my kids about
this stuff yet we're going to talk about
it this
weekend cuz I was I was talking to my
therapist and she's like what are you
afraid of like going into this interview
you know I'm like I'm nervous or
whatever she's like what what's
basically like what's the worst thing
that could happen and I'm like you know
there's stuff that my kid my kids
know but there's they don't know the
details they don't know like you know
that and my ex-husband is a douche like
he's just a Terri terrible human and he
tells kids things that they don't ever
need to know and he vilified me and
alienated me any chance that he got and
so I don't actually you know I know that
there were things said to them that in
that time frame that he should have
never said and I've done the um done the
work to try
to not not just rebuild like cuz we've
done that we've we are definitely
rebuilding our relationship but um but
also sort of combat whatever effect that
he had on them and their relationship to
me and we have great
relationships but you know to talk about
the details of my addiction with them
is um it just hasn't happened I mean I
wrote them
letters as they got older and uh just
deeply apologized they're young men too
they're like I don't really want to have
an emotional conversation with you I
just wrote them letters and let them
read them in their own time and maybe
separ from me maybe you just set the
record straight here
yeah right well that's sort of the thing
is like you
know I'll I'll have talked to them
before they ever see this we tried to
coordinate one last weekend like a
family meeting and then we're trying to
coordinate one for this coming weekend
because everyone's busy um and just talk
to them because they're old enough now
they're old enough to talk to them about
the details of my of of what my life was
in that time and and for them to to
understand that
like people people don't become drug
addicts because
they're shitty people it's not people
don't become drug addicts because they
lack willpower
or they're just not strong enough or
some kind of moral failing it's because
they have it's a it's a shitty coping
skill it's I don't know how to cope with
my feelings or my life or the stuff
that's happened so I'm going to reach
for something and you know sometimes
there's the coincidence that a doctor
prescribes you some [__] pills I had
a my doctor prescribed me colipan I'm
like 7 years sober having panic attacks
cuz I'd never been diagnosed yet I was
formally diagnosed with PTSD by a
[__] medical doctor who's like oh let
me give you some colanapins and Prozac
and a sleep aid and all this [__] and
I'm like in hindsight like why would you
ever do that like why would you open up
the Super Highway of the addiction
Pathways in my brain when I'm clearly in
duress I'm having panic
attacks but it's because it was a
medical doctor she didn't fully
understand addiction she didn't it it
was you know 15 years ago she didn't she
didn't know what she was dealing with
and that and in a year and a half I was
an IV heroin
addict I went went to a music festival
I'd gone to a million times before on
kipin cakil Prozac all this [__] and
picked up a beer and smoked smoked a
joint and like did coped with my
feelings with outside stuff and it was
Off to the Races I'm in a shitty
relationship with a secret drug addict I
just found out like I'm going to do
whatever feels natural and it wasn't a
big deal to throw away 7 years this
Friday because those Pathways in my mind
were already opened by these [__]
Pharmaceuticals that she gave me like
colipan is like a beer and a pill like
all my feelings are gone all my stress
is gone I'm in [__] Bliss I don't
have to think about my childhood or
anything else like come on it's
ridiculous I mean I think they know more
now they know a lot more than they
did um and I don't blame anybody I'm
I'm I have this
superpower to go through terrible
terrible
[__] and it wasn't always like this and
I've and for
for 75 to 80% of my life I was a victim
I was like if you [__] experienced
what I did
too you would do everything I've done
because poor me poor me I'm a [__]
victim of my life and my parents and
these shitty men and whatever and maybe
that's true because there are certainly
times where I didn't [__] make that
choice you know what I mean I didn't
make those choices for my parents I
didn't choose to be raped I didn't
choose to have a [__] older boy
boyfriend who became my husband who was
abusive and mind [__]
me but it doesn't serve me to believe
that it doesn't serve me to believe
that I'm only what happens to me like
I'm I I I exist in this world based on
what happens to me
because then that's all you are all I am
is a victim that means I have no control
I don't have any say and that's [__]
because then what do you do then you
might as well [__] use or kill
yourself like what's the [__] point
of just like living a life where I'm
like cuz that's kind of that's kind of
my luck like I I have if I didn't have
bad luck I wouldn't have any at all and
if I if I don't accept that and say like
okay well where's the lesson in this
where is the value in this pain because
it's not going to be for nothing I'm not
going to experience
heartache and
pain and have a be for nothing it's got
to be for something so there's a lesson
somewhere and I've been going through it
like simultaneously having miracles
happen and huge opportunity and just
really going through it too because
I made
choices that have long-term impacts on
my
life broken little Diana made choices
for me and I'm paying for
him but it's like one foot in front of
the
other I got to unfuck myself I've got to
I've got to get to a place where like
the whole goal for me was like I want a
boring quiet life for me and my kids I
want to own some dirt I don't want to
have like fire escape Gardens my entire
life I want to have like some space for
us and and that was like the objective
that's all I did and that's and and I
achieved it and now like the the huge
[__] irony is that
like I did it with somebody who I who I
should I had no business being a
relationship with gave them some
ownership when they didn't even buy it I
bought
it and I can't
refinance you're still learning oh yeah
F [__] yeah of course I always be always
for the rest of my life I hope I hope
that I never feel like I haven't figured
out I hope I never feel like
I'm I there's this term that people say
recovered like I'm
recovered I worked for this artist in
Vermont once is I was a chainsaw Carver
and I still I'm like dabbling on the
side and he was like I'm in the advanced
class I don't go to AA anymore I go to
allanon cuz I'm not the problem
everybody else is I'm like what the [__]
man like he drinking old d in the bar
like trying to pick up women I'm like
you're [__] miserable like you're not
happy the whole point to me is like to
be happy like I want to be happy and not
need anything I want to possess
everything I need to feel okay to feel
loved to feel like you know I can cope
with my feelings and life and that's
sort of the whole for me and I'm sure
it's individual to everybody is like I
recovery or sobriety is I'm not reaching
for anything out ins side of me like I
possess all the skills that I need to
deal with my life and my
feelings um because I wasn't taught that
I had to learn it and I [__] fail all
the time like the the the stronger the
emotional attachment to a situation the
worse I respond like it's just autopilot
and that's kind of the work I've been
trying to do lately is like that
autopilot stuff that like changing
those those thought processes and
and it's happening it's happening when I
look at like look at my past and these
you know big breakups Trauma from
relationships and one two three one one
relapse two relapse three no [__]
relapse didn't
even and and I went through this
traumatic event where my PTSD was fully
triggered and I'm on like the other side
of it and I'm and I took a day off of
work cuz I hadn't slept in days I didn't
even shower because I was too scared to
shower to be vulnerable in my own house
and I'm sitting on the porch talking to
my my brother in the sunshine on this
porch that I bought and I'm like
realizing that I'd gone through this
really traumatic event where my whole
nervous system responded like you are
going to die and not once did it cross
my mind to drink or
use that's a great sign that's [__]
amazing that's not supposed to happen
that's not supposed to [__] happen my
brain is supposed to want to escape it's
supposed to want to run the [__] away
from scary stuff it's run as fast as you
can
and it's mushrooms it's micro doing
neuroplasticity and like retraining the
neural Pathways in my to be able to
actually see other options instead of
only having this tunnel vision when when
it feels like my childhood when it feels
like these deep deep memories of like
this is what's always happened you're
micro doing with what
silicion I have and it create and it it
changed things it it absolutely did I
mean I had that was the first time I had
actual evidence that something is
different because it wasn't until I was
on the other side of it where I went
through an event that I've been through
many times in my life where my partner
was making me feel afraid and I was
scared for my [__] life and I didn't
use or drink I didn't even think about
it I didn't even think about
it recovery is like the thoughts will
always be there that's the idea that's
what we're told the thoughts will always
be there you just create a buffer
between the thought and the action you
don't destroy your life because you're
scared and it was like direct evidence
said it was working great yeah it it's
amazing all right Diana thank you so
much for sharing your story yeah we you
wish you lots of continued success
that's the plan thank you
yeah